[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en el español
hoy vamos a hablar de política de arte
de ciudadanía y de américa latina para
ello saludamos a distancia en razón de
las medidas de seguridad social a
olivier dabène autor de un apasionante
libro que lleva por título de street art
y democracy en latinoamérica el arte de
la calle en américa latina' disponible
por ahora solo en inglés
olivier dabène yo recuerdo que usted es
director del opal que el observatorio
político para américa latina y el caribe
del instituto de ciencias políticas y
sociales en parís y también miembro de
miembro perdón del ser y el centro de
estudios internacionales dice usted que
el street art el arte de la calle es una
forma de expresión social pero también
de disputa política qué quiere decir con
esto
bueno un placer estar contigo y gracias
por la invitación bueno si hace rato
hace tiempo que realmente las paredes de
las grandes ciudades son objeto de
apropiación por gente que quiere
expresarse y en los últimos en las
últimas décadas ha cobrado una
importancia muy particular dada la
crisis de credibilidad de la democracia
representativa ya la gente ya no cree
más en partidos políticos políticos y
representantes así que buscan maneras de
expresar directamente a través de en
este caso del arte y las grandes
ciudades de américa latina' ofrecen
miles de posibilidades de realmente
mandar un mensaje expresarse tratar de
impactar la opinión pública en casi
todas las grandes ciudades observamos
eso ahora obviamente el primer contacto
con este trabajo que usted ha realizado
data del 2006 dice ustedes comenzó en
sao paulo pero realmente su trabajo de
investigación de campo si se puede decir
es en 2013 2016
y 2018 va usted a entrevistar personas
en colombia en sao paulo en valparaíso
en oaxaca y en la habana cinco ciudades
porque cinco ciudades y no otras
bueno cada una de esa ciudad representa
una forma de interacción entre el
trabajo que hacen los artistas en la
calle la apropiación del espacio público
y la digamos la gobernanza o sea la
respuesta de las autoridades así que
diferentes ciudades vamos a tener por
ejemplo a arte es un arte subversivo que
quiere mandar mensajes radicales y que
chocan con una actitud de únicamente
represiva por parte las autoridades en
otras ciudades y autoridades más
abiertas más tolerantes que consideran
que eso es arte y hay que defenderlo
hasta hasta hay que usarlo para decorar
las ciudades que desde ahora ya hay aquí
un es un atractivo turístico ya el arte
dije que era colombia evidentemente
estamos haciendo referencia a la ciudad
de bogotá usted señala que los artistas
que usted entrevistó reivindican su
trabajo como una forma de transgresión
pero al mismo tiempo como una forma de
diálogo
correcto o sea lo interesante para un
artista es realmente entrar en espacio
público de esto estamos hablando de un
espacio donde se puede dialogar con la
ciudadanía se puede lanzar ideas se
puede advertir se puede mandar noticias
se puede provocar emociones todas en una
categoría de digamos de reacciones que
pueden tener como impacto pues mejorar
el conocimiento que tiene la gente de
grandes problemas
en los países no solamente provocar
emociones hay también hay artistas que
no tienen necesariamente mensajes
políticos y simplemente quieren divertir
o provocar una emoción así cuando en las
grandes ciudades caminando en las calles
todo cristo estresado ofrecen un segundo
un minuto
y sueño de ese a de de emoción
efectivamente el escritor te acompaña a
los movimientos sociales es por ejemplo
el caso de chile muy concretamente pero
al mismo tiempo no siempre es frontal no
siempre choca con la política porque
esta discreción si se puede decir así
bueno si es cierto lo que dice eso se
hace además hace mucho mucho tiempo que
los de los artistas acompañan
movimientos sociales pero la verdad es
que en el libro también estoy analizando
el arte fuera de los periodos de
inmovilización y me parece interesante
también y en ese caso pues en el día a
día de la vida de las grandes ciudades
independientemente del ánimo de la gente
pues tenemos un grupo de artistas que
quieren realmente expresarse o que
quieren mandar un mensaje por ejemplo
mensaje a los políticos estamos
observando lo que es lo que hacemos y
que estamos exigiendo la rendición de
cuentas y no vamos a aceptar más
violaciones de los derechos humanos
la pintura que acabas de demostrar es
bastante significativa así que un
ambiente lo analizo en el libro como una
fuerte contribución a la democracia
porque estamos hablando de jóvenes a
veces que nunca van a ir a votar no
tiene interés en la política pero si
quieren existir quieren existir y
quieren vivir su ciudadanía urbana como
gente que expresan en el espacio público
ideas sobre temas globales a veces
podría decirse que es el excluido que
busca una forma de reconocimiento de
inclusión social
sí exactamente por ejemplo si tomamos el
caso extremo del pisa son típicamente
del southampton pues el brasil sí y
específicamente en sao paulo porque no
todo brasil pues es una manera de decir
yo existo y lo
y nadie me ve en la vida cotidiana en el
tiempo normal entre comillas porque yo
vivo en la periferia muy lejano del de
los centros de las de las clases medias
y lo que voy a hacer es ensuciar las
paredes de los barrios de las clases
medias para para para decir yo yo soy
alguien yo soy una persona humana
también tengo mis emociones también y es
un grito existencial para decirlo así
justamente usted habla del caso de de
sao paulo esta expresión de este estilo
pillado al mismo tiempo dice que bogotá
puede ser considerada la meca de el
graffiti se puede hablar de una escuela
o de escuelas del street art
si definitivamente y escuelas los
artistas reconocen de dónde vienen los
artistas pero es mucho más complicado
que simplemente distinciones por países
ya en la ciudad de sao para los hampones
tan grande como un país sea entonces
nada más en la ciudad de sao paulo vamos
a tener un estilo en el este otro estilo
en el oeste otro estilo del sur igual en
bogotá o bocatín tiene muchas
localidades y lo que los que pintan en
el puro centro pues van a hacer cosas
diferentes distintas de las localidades
lejanas
donde no hay tanto atractivo no hay
tanto tanta gente para ver las obras
pero si hay a esa misma voluntad de
expresarse yo creo que es esto realmente
lo más importante hay como una especie
de confrontación olivier dabène de lo
que sale de su libro entre el graffiti
vamos a decir entre comillas el
delincuente que mancha a paredes ya que
el artista del street art que busca
precisamente con sus murales darle una
expresión social de embellecer la ciudad
es correcta este de la apreciación
correcta pero hay que matizar porque la
verdad es que puede ser la misma persona
que pinta un mural muy bonito durante el
día a veces con un financiamiento
oficial de la alcaldía que paga un
artista para decorar una pared grande un
mural esa misma persona puede salir en
la noche para rayar para cachar como lo
ven aquí eso es un valparaíso una foto
de valparaíso y eso es vandalismo pero
pero pues a la misma persona eso es lo
impresionante porque realmente
para el artista el carácter subversivo y
legal medio secreto así durante la noche
es importante es parte de la identidad
de lo que hacen pero al mismo tiempo
tienen que vivir tienen que ganarse la
vida de alguna manera y entonces vender
su arte a las autoridades para decorar
un muro etcétera es una manera de no de
vender sus almas realmente porque
siempre tratan de preservar una cierta
autonomía y no van a obedecer a ninguna
instrucción de pintar tal o tal cosa lo
van a hacer negociando una cierta
libertad pero puede ser la misma persona
es parte de una identidad hacen
diferentes cosas y nadie solamente
no solamente en esa posición simple
entre vandalismo y arte más complicado
dos años de investigación de campo más
de 77 entrevistados hombres y mujeres
como sucede el street art a un nivel de
a nivel de género hay confrontación
hombres y mujeres por el espacio del
street art
es realmente un mundo muy masculino muy
macho trate en el libro de encontrar
mujeres artistas hay una vez más de
hecho hasta hay libros ahora que salen
sobre mujeres en el street art de
américa latina' así que hay cada vez más
pero sigue siendo un mundo un poco un
poco machista
las mujeres no solamente dicen que están
defendiendo el género sino más bien una
forma de pintar que tal vez es menos
violenta no a esa digamos esa
competencia para pintar algo cada vez
más grande cada vez más espectacular y
las mujeres que yo que yo entreviste
también le dan mucha importancia al
proceso creativo que tiene que ser
solidario con comunidades y no quieren
entrar solo escuché varias veces en
bogotá por ejemplo que no quieren entrar
esa competencia entonces más allá del
género es una forma de contemplar el
arte que es un poco diferente de la 5
ciudad de donde usted hizo su
investigación de campo llamó mi atención
claro todas pero
quisiera centrarme en el caso de la
habana hay una gran cantidad de artistas
de la calle al mismo tiempo es una
confrontación permanente de espacio
contra el autoritarismo contra el
centralismo del gobierno
en el caso de la habana para mí para mi
trabajo de investigador es un caso que
llamaríamos como el extremo o con poca
probabilidad de encontrar una
contribución a la democracia porque
estamos habló de un régimen autoritario
sin embargo encontré la gente fascinante
absolutamente fascinante que realmente
están pintando en la calle a veces
hablando con la policía para saber si se
puede pintar esa esa esquina aquí porque
de todas maneras está en ruinas el
trofeo así que por qué no belleza en
poco
a veces colocan cosas ambigua que dan
espacio para varias interpretaciones y
es ahí donde yo creo que eso es una
contribución de la democracia cada vez
un artista pinta algo sin imponer un
sentido particular dejando a la persona
que ver la obra a esa libertad de
interpretar y pensar por uno mismo por
sí mismo interpretar en un contexto
autoritario es muy político y es muy
democrático es como tratar de que de
hacer que la gente tenga su propia
opinión cosa que repito en un país como
cuba es bastante subversivo bueno pues
el tiempo lamentablemente se nos ha ido
olivier dabène gracias por haber estado
con nosotros recuerdo que usted es autor
de street art and democracy en
latinoamérica esperamos que pronto se ha
traducido en español y también que usted
es director del observatorio político
para américa latina el opal a ustedes
les damos las gracias hasta muy pronto
en otra nueva emisión de escala en parís
[Música]